这个讨论好久
是今天这个我
觉得应该比较清晰了
你之前卡的问题
对
之前那个我听完了之后
感觉好像有点思路怎么做
但是具体要做的时候
我又打不开那个东西
所以今天我觉得你应该就很清晰
我觉得至少六月份你输出的东西应该就比较完整
可以
整体这边的核心就是我们刚才说这些了
主要是商城
我感觉这个工作量不大
这个
是是是
好长城那边可能你要综合考虑了
行行
3D这边应该就是那个UI样式
你需要确定下来
然后我们我们可能要再调整一波
因为现在的是按照现在的样式去做
我们现在用下来因为你你这边用的颜色是带边框的
这样的话你但是你的颜色对比其实没有很强烈
主要是靠那个边框去去界定范围
导致我们这边有些UI它跟背景混的颜色会非常分区分不了
其实你说的右边的这种属性面板也要去掉边框是不是
对
就是这个面板我们这个地方这些边框的话最好是能去掉
我们现在是就是有有一些
这是我们的吗
你看这里我们是能做一些这些边框
但是这个边框说实话做起来不是很好看
就是这种高高亮的颜色说实话做起来不是很好看
就是你最好是用那种对比比较强烈的一点
不要边框
我们我们可以去改这个
改就是你高亮的话
我你像这一些我们都是有颜色修改
这样是可以的
但是像这种带边框的颜色修改
我们这边做起来就很丑
因为他那个引擎的渲染对这一块支持不太好
所以就是整一个仿真的页面里面尽可能少的用这个边框
就是基本上不要那个边框了
最好是这
对对对
然后还有一个就是刚刚那个仿真的
就是看你这边你这边考虑一下是比如说到那个裸体的时候
他是要单独有一个面板出来去选哪个区
还是说直接就从右边出来
这个就是看你这边考虑一下
就出来一个字
你现在刚刚的那个那个弹窗那里
我再明确看一下这个
组合窗
对
就是刚刚不是
对对对这个就是其实我们运行的时候要考虑这一些选项的组合
对不对
然后他其实这个编译器相当于是3D这边的
然后blocky就blocking那边的流程图
流程图那边只有blocking是需要选区域的
其他两个都是不需要
其他两个是怎么样的
看一下
两个就是选中
就是选中了
没有我选去选中
然后只有然后block你这边选区的话
还要选一个主程序是有两级是不是
对对对
相当于你不可以选择他这边还有一个选区
OKOK
然后只有勾只有做了这个选项才能够运行这个程序
但是刚刚是不是说那个数据源选择这边只能选一种33选1对筛选
所以说我们意思就是做成那个做成现在这里的那种下拉框
你做成下拉框
然后我们在右边直接分出来
如果要做的话
要么是右边分出来一个子集的那个下拉框
要么就是写一个只有一个下拉框的一个面板
不过我们之前因为有做过那种只有一个下拉框面板
看起来有点太单薄了也有点奇怪
最好还是做成那种
他其实还有一个东西要考虑
就是说它运行的模式里面是这个真机
仿真还是孪生
这个也要选择
对不对
那我们可能就是两个下拉框了
就是两个在这边
这模式进行组合
两个下拉框有个问题
就是说两个下拉框配置完了之后
还有一个运行跟暂停
对不对
然后他有可能就是用户有可能就有没有可能忘记去选这个了
然后运行了之后才记起来
那他他运行不了
没没选的话
你是运行不了的
我们当我们用
那你不要默认吗
那你3D假如说没建程序
默认的是哪个
那你运行的时候就是没程序
对
运行的就没程序
那就运行不了
对就行
那就不要默认
就不要默认了
对我们我们之前的话他是对于运行模式
它是会把这些功能全部给相当于把上面这个面板给整整个换掉
就是只有是有一个相当于一个运行的模式
它里面只有那个运行的模式
然后开始运行重置这些按钮
就是相当于你点完之后是进入了一个新的状态
因为你把所有的东西都放在这个地方的话
我们之前我们这边有有试有试过
现在这个地方就已经很拥挤了
你如果再去放其他的一些功能
我们这个地方可能会过大
同意
首先运行起来
这些功能已经不用了
对不对
对对对
就按理说他们要么是隐藏
要么就是开
我们运行是一个单独
的一个上面的对
你看他就是把其他的按钮隐藏了这种
对对对
那那我我我综合考虑一下
我怎么样切换一下
就这个来去配
还有一个这个你也是为或者还有一个方式
你可以思考一下
利用一下底部
就像那种播放器那种感觉
但是他说运行起来的时候
上面这条是没有的
对我的意思是你就放你就放底部
比如说底部类似播放器
然后它一播放
然后就隐藏这样的
就像国防七那种感觉
一点​‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​‌‌​​​‌‌​​​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌​​​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌​​​‌‌​‌​‌​​‌‌‌‌​‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌​‌‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌‌‌‌‌​​‌‌​‌‌‌​​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​‌‌‌‌​‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​​‌‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌‌​​‌​​‌‌​‌​‌‌‌​‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌‌仿真按钮之后
这边就消失掉了
换成仿真的那些按钮
对
只有仿真的那些按钮
这样的话就行了
如果用下面那个播放器的话
你你要你如果关闭还要鼠标移下去
它又显又瘾的感觉
有因为那种有点太偏偏向于视频播放了
我感觉有点奇怪
那就这边你你那边去考虑一下就可以
对
看下哪种形式比较好
行行好的
我们我们再再总结一下
是不是还有其他没有的话
可以总结一下
刚刚那个
没有了
没有这边是没有了
是首先那个夹爪的这一块
我这边提供的就是侧边的这个面板
对不对
对然后还有就是这两个刚刚那个绿色盒子的这个调节的交互
对对对
然后其他的地方就不需要了
然后下一个的话就是刚刚说那个什么边框的问题
我把它全部给去掉
是的
对对对
然后再下一个就是整个运行的这个菜单逻辑
对
就是仿真的菜单逻辑
行行
还有吗
还有你把边框
去掉之后
要把把交互的那些组件的颜色要统一下
然后列一个表格给我
对对对
我这边要统统一下颜色
好好好的行
所以这边就四个点
然后就是那个商城的
我先根据刚刚讨论的理解
我先出一版
对对我觉得现在基本上需求比较清晰
了对对对
清晰多
好好好
那就尽快搞好
好嘞好嘞好好
好行
那今天先这样
辛苦大家了
拜拜